JASON SILVA: You know, if I
had to verbalize what I believe
accounts for the failure of most
of my romantic relationships
is the fact that I can
not bear love's aging.
I cannot stand the dissolution
of the honeymoon phase, right.
As soon as the vacation,
the electrifying vitality,
the rapture of
meeting someone new
fades it's a kind
of death practice.
You die a little.
When enthralment
dissipates you kind of
have a moment of profound
tragic realization
that everything passes, that our
greatest ecstasies are imbued,
are cast upon by a shadow of
dread, of knowing that this
will pass, that this will end.
So what do we do when we look
into the iris of a lover's eye,
right?
When being seen
by the person you
love so much gives
you goose bumps,
makes you cry, touches your
core, touches your soul,
titillates everything
inside of you.
Makes you think of that
Roland Barthes books,
"Lover's Discourse," about
how the cradling that
takes place between two
people when they finally
feel safe, like Adam and
Eve in the garden of Eden
before the tree of knowledge,
before knowledge of death,
and of transience was known.
See, I want to live in
that garden of Eden.
I fantasize about it.
I watch movies about it.
I listen to beautiful
songs about it.
Curiosity killed the cat.
I ate from the
tree of knowledge.
I learned about death, and
mortality, and endings,
and entropy.
And I think that
that has haunted
all of my relationships,
this terror
of the inevitable ending,
and I'm still dealing
with finding a hack for that.
That's the truth.
[MUSIC PLAYING]